welcome everyone i'm jacqueline
goldstein i'm chair of the african
american studies department and it's
really really wonderful to be able to
welcome you to
the first in a series of endeavors
colloquiums for this semester
i won't let it go without saying that i
wish we could be
gathering together in
physical real time space with each other
at the department's building on campus
81 wall street in the gordon park
seminar room where we traditionally hold
these
thought
gatherings these think tanks
um but
we are where we are with the pandemic
and there are ways in which zoom
actually makes different kinds of
convenience possible
um that actually have led to some having
some exciting
thought leaders here with us today so we
will run with the virtual space and i'm
but i don't want to let let it go
without saying that um we would
traditionally be holding this
in our department building but we are in
the zoom space and i just want to point
out a few logistical uh points for all
of us to get today you should have
received the
um
message that we are recording this
session
um and we will be posting it online so
that it's available to
anyone
to think with the ideas that are going
to be raised here today but for that
reason we would ask that you mute your
mics
um so that we can have a kind of clean
soundtrack for the recording
and also when we turn to q a but as the
discussion evolves and and moves feel
free to post your questions your
comments your thoughts in the chat and
our facilitator for today will be
tracking on that space and bring your
ideas and bring your voices into the
discussion when we hit that part of the
program
um i just want to flag for us that this
is the first in the series of
colloquia that we'll be having this
spring
um
and to remind us all and especially for
those of you who are new and our guests
that uh there are a couple of unique
features about the endeavors series it's
worth naming since we're coming back
together um after not holding
the series last semester
one thing about our department
colloquium is that it's department wide
and other departments
tend to organize by subfields
but we bring everyone together
because in african american studies we
approach questions and issues
um and plan making we want to pursue
interdisciplinarily right bringing the
disciplines together and so we bring
everyone in this shared space
and another feature about our colloquium
is that it's a space for incubating and
fostering new ideas new art new
scholarship
new ways to be engaged in community work
and so we're really excited to be
thinking at the edge
of what's happening in our respective
disciplines but together
um to to move the new ideas to to push
the endeavors out hence the title of our
series
i want to point out that this semester
we're focusing on breakthrough ideas
breakthrough models breakthrough
provocations that are coming to us from
the social sciences and so we'll be
convening
sociologists political scientists
psychologists economists anthropologists
to really push our thinking about the
leading issues that are shaping black
life worlds today
and so i just want to mark some future
dates for you
on march 31st
my colleague professor amy cox will
facilitate a panel discussion on the
anthropology of abolition
which will bring together really
exciting um anthropologists who are
setting the carceral state and state
violence
um and then we're looking and finalizing
panels for april
where we'll focus on race and higher
education
and the case for reparations which as
you know at yale is a very live
discussion given the work of the yale
and slavery working group so those
panels will be happening in april and as
soon as we confirm the speakers will let
you know but do mark
march 31st where we'll have savannah
same change uh chat kristen smith and
deborah thomas with us to talk about the
anthropology of abolition
today's panel on black activism amidst
community violence will be facilitated
by my colleague professor philip gough
and i'll hand it over to professor goff
to introduce our panelists today
thank you so much jackie
for those introductory remarks and for
all of your your leadership of this
department that allows us uh to have
these kinds of conversations i wanted to
make sure that my mute off button has
worked so can i get a thumbs up that um
from the panelists that folks are
hearing me thank you so much
um
it's a rare pleasure um in doing
academic work that you get to hear from
national leaders together in
conversation that's part of what we're
trying to do this semester
to in part compensate for zoom and to
create a little bit more sense of of
community so it's a rare pleasure that
we get to do that
it is also a rare pleasure to be able to
do that while talking to people i've
considered friends for a number of years
um so i'm mostly going to want to get
out of the way i'm going to do a little
bit of housekeeping and do a little bit
of
sort of shaping of it but i mostly want
you all to get a chance to experience
the genius we have
been so fortunate to collect um for
today um the little bit of housekeeping
um as uh
uh jackie had uh mentioned uh previously
uh
if you can please mute your video and
your mic throughout because we are doing
a recording um if you've got questions
please please please put it on the uh
put it in the chat and i will go ahead
and facilitate that when it comes time
to the the q a and for ease of your own
viewing if you if you would like we
encourage you to go ahead and put uh uh
the presentation on speaker view um just
as we move through um with that let me
go ahead and frame this conversation
that i i couldn't be more excited to
just be listening to i know i got to
facilitate it too
which is this
the past two years have seen
the largest single set of protests in
human history by all accounts
they were around racial injustice in our
public safety and policing systems in
the united states but they went global
those protests and the organizing and
activism that surrounded them that was
in response to them
has not stopped
and yet
at the same time
the
the levers the pendulum of uh sort of
racial uh momentum
have shifted in those two years from one
of a of a international appetite um for
significant change not just in criminal
legal systems but of course all the
systems that feed into them to one where
just today we're hearing stories that
all of those protests in fact were a
fool's errand um that they have gone far
too far
and that they have they have asked for
and even pushed achieved too much
the reality of course is that while
protests um were massive and demands
were radically um sort of
oriented the amount that has changed is
much smaller um that is in the national
narrative
and all of that is within the context of
a controversial controversially
affiliated
spike
not in crime
but in murder in violence within
communities
and in fact it is that spike in in
violence within communities that has led
many folks to say well these new demands
these new policies must be at fault we
must go back to where things were this
is overreach
first let me say
that
we have to acknowledge the murder spike
is real
it is not some form of propaganda it is
not faked data i specialize in
identifying fake data particularly in
public safety and the most reliable data
that you can get ever from law
enforcement are those that can be double
checked at the morgue black communities
have been hurting
in the midst of the last two years not
just from the pandemic not just from the
economic consequences thereof but from
community violence
and yet there is written nowhere a law
that says it is in fact when violence is
at its heightened communities that we
must rely on punitive institutions to
remedy it
the argument can easily be made if
police budgets were at their height in
the midst of this why on earth would we
need to increase policing
there is a significant question about
where and when and how policing as
opposed to community empowerment drives
down that violence prevents that
violence even predicts it
these questions are in the context of
the long struggle for black liberation
the tension between what do we need to
do right now amidst the hell that black
folks are catching and what do we need
to plan for in the future so that there
is a future where we're not demanding
justice but we're experiencing freedom
how do we move within that
what are the appropriate roles for
academia
and what do we see as the
the trends the promises within activism
organizing and a collective united voice
to demand changes in the experiences
that we're having right now
i could think of
no better group of humans to talk to us
about that than the four assembled
before us who will then go on to solve
all of these problems no pressure lobar
but we're going to be hearing from in
order
nikki jones who is a professor and h
michael and uh gene williams department
chair of african american studies
at the african american studies
department at uc berkeley
um
she is
one of the if not her generations my
generation's greatest ethnographers of
the forms of invisible violence we have
done to black people generally black
women and girls in particular that is
invisible that she makes visible
she's awarded the american society of
criminology
outstanding research award in 2020 her
list goes on and on
i encourage you uh to read between good
and ghetto her first book as well as her
many many articles the regular routine
all of them these are staples in my
classes um and have radically shaped the
way in which i think about these issues
she will speak first
second will be
patrick sharkey who is the william s
todd professor of sociology and public
affairs at princeton university perhaps
no one has written as careful and
nuanced uh a take on what is happening
in particularly urban pockets of
violence than pat sharkey
i will i can and will go on and on um
but he is perhaps most notably for this
if folks are looking for the website the
founder of americanviolence.org go there
it is an amazing resource and i i cannot
tell you how excited i am that he is
here to speak with us
third brandon terry who is a
presidential visiting assistant
professor here at yale this year he is
an assistant professor of african
american studies on american studies and
of social studies at harvard because he
likes to have multiple affiliations um
he is a preeminent thinker
and scholar of black radical political
thought
and i'm excited to hear how he's going
to be framing this moment in terms of
how black leadership
can and should be a continuation and a
departure of the legacies that we bring
with us
and last but certainly not least pastor
michael mcbride is a native son of san
francisco who's got a ministry in
oakland for over 20 years pastor mcbride
is the executive director of live free
usa a nonprofit committed to ending gun
violence he is an intellectual leader a
movement leader a moral leader on these
issues and well beyond um so mostly what
i want to do as i said is get the heck
out of the way to let these folks rip on
giving us some more wisdom with regards
to these issues
where the pendulum has not only swung
back but it has sharp edges and it is
pushing us further away from where we're
trying to go than we were before
the public lynching of george floyd may
25th 2020.
dr nikki jones could you please offer
some initial remarks before we get to
this to the q a and i'll introduce each
of them uh these folks after that yeah
and thank you professor goff for that
that introduction for the invitation to
be here uh thank you vanessa for all the
work that you did behind the scenes to
get us in this virtual space together
uh and thank you professor goldsby for
those introductory comments and and the
invitation to to think together
um i'm joining you here from from
berkeley unseated alone a territory uh
in in the bay area
i'm joining you at a moment that is
really a reflective moment for me um and
thinking about what we've learned from
the uprisings of summer 2020 but
especially in the context of policing
and and working in in the area of
policing over the course of my career
and seeing for the first time in in our
history where we are are seeing the the
pairing the intertwining of uprisings
against systemic racism and police
violence which is much different even
from seven years ago the call for for
police reform and so
that has been very clarifying for me so
thinking deeply about what black
activists have always encouraged us us
to do is to see things more clearly to
sharpen our vision uh to better
understand and define the problem and so
what are the things that that i i know
with more certainty both over the course
because of the work that i've done over
the course of my career and because of
of this particular moment first we know
and i think more people understand that
policing is not one thing and so we
often talk about policing writ large but
i think if we just think about the media
coverage of the black lives matter
protest or the uprisings of summer 2020
uh and the violence that was freely
distributed upon protesters
and then we think about the insurrection
on january 6 6 and people trying to make
sense of what they're seeing and the
reserve in which violence was held when
it when when the mob right when the the
uprising the insurrection uh was led by
white white people and and and to large
degree uh white nationalists and so
more folks understood that policing is
not the same always but certainly in the
work that i've done i i understood that
both in the ethographic work and
certainly came to appreciate that more
in the work that i've done interviewing
uh and studying police officers uh who
very uh freely share that policing is
not one thing they don't police uh
neighborhoods the same and that the
brunt of that violence
and aggression often comes down on the
bodies of black youth like those i've
i've spent time with over the course of
my career
i think this moment has also called on
us to think critically about policing as
a response to violence uh in a way that
we that that is is is much more refined
i think than we have previously and and
to better appreciate an argument that i
make in in my most recent book the
chosen ones that policing acts as a
co-constructor of violence and that's
not hyperbole
and it's not even a radical position to
say that policing is about violence
policing scholars have said this for uh
you know 50 50 plus years that violence
is is central to policing and
in the course of my my work as phil
alluded to uh certainly uh i am thinking
about the extraordinary forms of
violence and the spectacles of violence
that that we've come to to see and that
that motivate people but i've spent a
lot of time to thinking about the
ordinary violence the routine violence
and the way that the body becomes an
archive for that violence the body
becomes conditioned the bodies of young
people become conditioned to that
violence and i think we have other
archives of that as well we can think
about pattern and practice
investigations for example
and people often you know want to know
is this a kind of reform that can change
policing and i take a slightly different
look at these these records and think
about the ways in which it's an archive
of the routine violence of the ordinary
violence that is common until it's not
until it's made extraordinary by an act
but then if you look back you see that
the record of routine violence uh was
there and if that's the case then you
know i think we have to think critically
about what not the role of policing and
and responding to this this murderous
murder spike the spike in violence but
what is the role of state violence in
responding to violence and what are the
limits of that
and so certainly thinking uh about
the the kind of expanding the narrow way
in which we often thought about policing
as a response or as a provider of of
public safety
and then i think this moment what i hope
we have learned um and what i know uh
folks are pushing us to appreciate
is the way that this moment is an echo
it's an echo of earlier times going back
centuries right but it is an echo in
this moment a very recent history of the
80s and 90s right where we have these
racialized fears around
empirical facts so just like professor
goff said yes there is this fight how do
we respond to that and what is the role
of racialized fear so certainly the the
kind of the the racialized images of
black criminality are coming to the fore
whether they're explicitly uh you know
addressed or not
and it it makes it difficult for us to
really appreciate the depth of the
problem and so certainly there's we
think about gun violence it's
concentrated in cities and among black
black youth and latinx youth and yet we
know that there's been an increase in
domestic violence as well right and that
that's gun violence but that's not the
vision that that we are bringing when we
have this kind of really narrow way of
of thinking about the problem and it's
intentionally narrow right because it's
not actually about addressing uh the
problem
you know it's it's about politicizing
the problem and certainly political
power
uh so i am i'm so those are a few things
that are more clarified for me moving
through this moment and i appreciate and
i just want to so i'll close i'll stop
there for now but just to say that you
know i'm really looking forward to being
in in this conversation and learning
from the the other the other panelists
thank you
thank you so much dr jones dr sharkey
could you speak to the people a little
bit
yeah i'd love to thanks for having me
with this group uh i man i've learned so
much from uh
dr jones work it's it's it's great to be
on the same panel and to be at yale uh
where i think some of the
the best work probably the best work on
around these issues is happening um so i
started studying violence because the
more evidence i looked at the more i
began to think of violence as central to
understanding inequality in the u.s and
that's that's reciprocal so urban
inequality creates the conditions for
violence to emerge uh by concentrating
disadvantage in the us by bringing about
sustained disinvestment
in community core community institutions
by
leading to
a system of punishment and that's u.s
specific as well but through these
mechanisms urban inequality creates the
conditions for violence to emerge
but then violence amplifies and
reinforces inequality
and it does that directly by taking
young lives but it also does that by
impeding academic
performance and achievement by
influencing the economic outcomes of
young people
by enhancing mental illness by
undermining
communities
so that's the frame
at which i i started to see violence as
fundamental to understanding inequality
in the us and then the question is well
when we look at what has happened since
the 1990s so violence fell by roughly
half from
early 1990s to 2014
so what happened what brought about that
change
and that's why i started studying
community organizations
the movements that were happening in
neighborhoods across the country so when
in i think it was 2015 i sat down with
three graduate students uh basically
because we were unsatisfied with the
explanations for why violence fell read
all these these
inspiring books about organizations
and people who had mobilized
to retake public spaces and make them
safe for communities to march against
violence to to
mobilize to provide services for mental
illness
for addiction to provide basic services
like after-school programs and
communities that were hit hardest by the
rise of violence in the 70s and 80s
and so when we looked at national data
we were basically trying to figure out
okay
we have these explanations for why
violence felt what else was happening on
the ground and we looked we gathered all
the data that we could
in cities
across the country and we
found the stuff that other people had
found so there was a large-scale
increase in police forces
there were changes in
police tactics
there was a continued rise in
incarceration there was an expansion of
surveillance and closed-circuit camera
systems implemented in cities across the
country
but there was also something else that
we saw there was a mobilization of the
non-profit sector
that occurred at a national level so
these stories are told in terms of
heroic acts of individuals or specific
groups of people in a given neighborhood
and they should be told that way they
are heroic acts this is this is uh
my comments are not meant to diminish
the the
incredible work that's gone on in
neighborhoods cross country but what i
would point out
is that this was a national mobilization
that took place in the early 1990s the
non-profit sector particularly
organizations that were formed
to deal with violence but also just to
build stronger communities you can see
in the national
data this proliferation so what we did
in
in that first study where i looked at
the impact of this mobilization of
nonprofit organizations was to try to
identify
causal evidence to see whether there was
a causal impact of the expansion of the
nonprofit sector on violent crime uh and
in that first study that that we did
um delarum takiara was one of the
graduate students gerard torres espinoza
was another and uh kiara dads i want to
make sure to give them all
credit um
what we found is that so we exploited
kind of shocks in funding that led to
more nonprofits emerging to identify the
causal impact what we found is that in a
typical city a city with about 100 000
people
every 10 additional nonprofits that were
formed
to deal with violence to retake public
spaces to provide services to provide
housing to provide after-school programs
led to about a nine percent drop in the
murder rate
the implication of this is that in
addition to all those other changes that
get so much attention about shifts in
policing and incarceration and so forth
there was a mobilization that took place
in the communities hit hardest by
violence
that mobilization the expansion of
nonprofits played a central role in
contributing to the fall of violence
from the 1990s to the mid 2010s the
reason that's important is because when
you think about the explanations for why
violence fell or when you think about
the reactions to the recent rise in
violence in the u.s we immediately go
back to this knee-jerk reaction and
think about a response that is focused
on the institutions of punishment the
police and the prison system that is the
default response to a rise in violence
in the u.s
this evidence
provides a proof of concept that a
different approach is necessary the
groups that mobilized in the 1990s are
groups that were underfunded
that did not have national support
that were not seen as central actors in
the effort to deal with violence and yet
they had this enormous impact on the
decline in violence they played a
central role in that effort so this
observation is reinforced by a whole
bunch of randomized controlled trials uh
the evidence base has grown stronger and
stronger and what it tells us
is that we have had a model for a long
time that
assumes that to deal with rising
violence we have to turn back to the
institutions of punishment in the u.s
there is another model the the
groups and the people that have always
had the greatest capacity to control
violence are organizations that are
motivated by building stronger
neighborhoods by looking out for their
neighborhoods neighbors making sure
everybody's welcome in their community
making sure their communities stay
strong and no one falls through the
cracks
those organizations we now know we have
enough
evidence now
to know that those organizations have
the greatest capacity to control
violence and yet they've just never been
given the commitment and the resources
to do so in a sustained way so i think
you know the main message here is that
we can make a case for the work that
pastor mike is doing the work that's
going on around the country on the
merits of of justice uh we quit we can
uh uh praise the work that's going on
the incredible hard work that's gone on
without sufficient resources but we can
also make an
empirical case this work is not only a
how i think the world should work it is
backed up by extraordinary evidence at
this point
thank you dr sharkey
dr terry you want to speak to the people
uh so first off i want to thank
phil for convening us here for inviting
me really honored to be in conversation
with you all who have learned so much
from and been inspired by
i'm a political theorist so i come at
these questions from a bit of a
different advantage
and i wanted to open up by speaking
forthrightly of what i think is a kind
of ghost haunting these kinds of
discussions about community violence and
that's the older idea or concept of
black on black crime
community violence is arrayed
productively against this earlier once
prominent idea and it's an attempt to
replace race-based with place-based
arguments
but for someone like me who was formed
in many respects by the 1990s period
that that pat is talking about the
decline of black on black crime talk is
really fascinating so it was once a
familiar part of black liberal
nationalist and radical discourse but
now is principally used by conservative
critics of black lives matter uh writers
like ta-nehisi coates decry its use as
ideological and cynical uh they say it
represents an illicit changing of the
subject against legitimate demands of
anti-racist activists and sociologically
i think the consensus is that black on
black violence concepts
lead analysts to confuse the effects of
racial segregation for a unique
pathology of black people think it
unfairly racializes crime further
stigmatizes blacks uh and perhaps even
more devastating is that the concept
seems to suggest the need for an
explanation of why uh to quote alvin
poussin's book title from the 1970s
blacks kill blacks
and this this peculiar demand for an
explanation tends to generate uh odd
black psychology in poussin's form it
drew on the wretched of the earth and he
wrote things like
by attacking a fellow black we may feel
that we are committing a manly act the
destruction of sin itself we may express
our self-rejection by acting out the
white racist wish
so this
uh idea of internalized oppression
despite its origins and black power
radicalism licensed surprising support
for authoritarian and violent repression
of black crime and black people as black
radicals themselves became more
despairing of the prospects for the
revolution and consciousness they might
shed these supposed pathologies through
politics
now
given the flaws of the picture i just
painted it's easy to narrate the turn to
the community violence concept as
progressive and an instance of genuine
sociological learning but i think
if we're too triumphant about that story
i think we missed something about the
popularity of black on black crime
discourse in black communities that
might help us to produce a still more
effective theory politics and rhetoric
in the present
so i think there's a slight of hand in
the way that some analysts conflate the
white dominated discourse about black
crime from the 1890s and its obsessions
with black on white crime especially
rape
with the discourse on black on black
crime a century later
the latter was not driven by
white racist and black reactionaries
alone but was embraced by all manner of
anti-racist artists intellectuals
activists from jesse jackson to sister
soldier to tupac shakur
and what we tend to miss i think is that
black on black crime talk can
essentially be split into two
overlapping but analytically distinct
families of thought
the first which we've discussed already
is sociological and explanatory in its
aspiration
the other however is normative
uh it's about ethics and politics so in
its normative construction black on
black crime reflects views about social
critique and moral duties the argument
was that black on black violence was not
just a problem but a matter of justice
it reflects unremedied effects of
broader systemic injustice and social
abandonment it intensifies unfair racial
stigma and violates basic rights of
blacks themselves
further the failure of the state to
effectively enforce the rule of law or
exhibit meaningful concern when blacks
harm other blacks reflects a cultivated
disregard for black dignity and
citizenship
and as my friend tommy shelby argues in
dark ghettos such conditions call into
question the very legitimacy of the
whole legal and political order as well
as the demand that the oppressed comply
with the law or that they respect
property rights or contribute to norms
of cooperation
the problem
with this critique however is that it
opens up a dangerous and frightening
moral and political void
how can we sustain respect for rights
how can we sustain cooperative struggles
against injustice how can we sustain
collective survival and flourishing
without the appeal to legitimate law
on my view what black on black crime
talk tried to do
was use racial solidarity to fill that
void
in other words it offers an argument to
those considering violence or criminal
practices which presuppose violence and
it suggests that such violence is not
just a violation of people's natural
rights but violates special solidarity
norms like special concern loyalty the
promotion of shared goals and trust
these goals the framework suggests are
necessary for the struggle against
anti-black racism and the cultivation of
a bearable social life amidst injustice
black on black violence on their view
then is a violation of obligations born
of shared oppression instead of
strengthening solidarity it deepens and
hardens patterns of distrust makes it
harder to sustain cross-class ties and
create psychological and social traumas
that make the work of movement building
harder it also events as a kind of cruel
parasitism amidst shared vulnerability
now in closing and to reiterate i'm not
offering a defense of the discourse but
i'm just pointing out how different it
looks from this normative angle as
opposed to the explanatory one
despite its faults black on black crime
talk properly reconstructed seems to
take seriously a broad suite of
challenges that i think any replacement
discourse concerned with black activism
amidst community violence also needs to
consider
i'll close by restating them quickly as
follows
the first is a critique of the
legitimacy of the existing social and
legal order and a related recognition
that certain forms of law breaking
are forms of legitimate descent
second is a recognition that this
critique discloses a crisis of
normativity that's severely dangerous to
social life and demands a kind of
normative refounding
third is a question of how to be
respectful of and responsive to the
moral and political agency of the
perpetrators and victims of violence
and last is responding to existing
normative expectations of black
solidarity and anti-race struggle
it's erased a struggle so i think this
helps us see more clearly what was
normatively self-undermining about the
answers black on black crime discourse
tended to generate to the incisive
ethical and political questions it posed
its proponents failed to adequately
distinguish their normative and
explanatory ambitions and they left the
concept vulnerable to usurpation by
authoritarian reactionaries the fixation
on the spectacular character of violence
moreover often degenerated into what we
see as one-sided demands for solidarity
discipline expressed by black elites
against the ghetto poor without
equal attention to the failure of mutual
concern in the other direction and
finally and most perniciously it
reflects the roots in black nationalism
by permitting the conceptual
partitioning of political space and
moral responsibility such that black on
black crime became only a challenge for
the supposed autonomous politics of
black communities rather than generating
duties of response for the whole society
to the extent that any community
violence paradigm fails to pose these
important normative questions or
reflexively reproduces these flaws i
think will undermine some of the
important potential gained in moving
from black on black crime talk to
community violence talk that we
supposedly are experiencing i'll stop
there
thank you so much dr terry and
by way of transition i love to move from
the ghosts of racism to the holy ghost
so pastor mike you want to go ahead and
bless the people
touch your neighbor with consent uh when
you introduce me talking about the holy
ghost i'm gonna get excited now um it's
great to be here with everyone uh
obviously um
you know so much has been said i agree
with all of it i i i would like to
introduce uh my perspective or remarks
just around this
this idea that
of of my greatest concern
this moment presents to me
it is around narrative and it is around
how we make meaning
of the worst conditions
in black and brown communities
um in a manner that does not re
um
uh re
uh cycle the very things that so many
reasonable people last several years had
an epiphany around um it is a question
to me not just the proximity but of
empathy it is a question of
do we believe that black communities
belong
to the united states of america or are
we a burden
and we just want black folks and others
to die silently
and invisibly
without the responsibility of the whole
nation
to fix what the nation broke
right
and and i do believe we are in a
priceless moment because you know i'm 46
years old i
lived through the 90s as a teenager
and i got caught up in being a victim of
police brutality
i have friends who have been beat up by
cops i have friends who've been shot and
killed by good
and so while some may have the luxury to
uncouple
the issue of policing and quote-unquote
intra-communal violence the overwhelming
majority of black folks caught in these
cycles both uh directly or uh through
proximity with their family members are
waking up every day trying to navigate
the the the existential presence of
violence in their lives that could come
upon them unexpected with no protection
and with no security
it is really important i think for us to
appreciate that it is a false
distinction between a victim and a
perpetrator
it is about where you come into the
story of that person
will we treat them as the victimized or
the victimizer
violence creates all kinds of trauma
that without therapy and support and
healing
remains in the soul the spirit the body
and the mind of the person who's been
victimized and so when we talk about
violence in our communities and we try
to divide even within our own
communities folks into good versus bad
you know victim versus perpetrator it
really muddies the water in a way that i
believe
uh caused us to lose out on the
opportunity to talk about communal
killing
um communal stabilization
and what must be done to stabilize black
communities that have not spent one day
in this country and not experience state
violence at the hands
of largely white led institutions now
what you think about that right
not one day in this country have we not
experienced the violence of white land
institutions both governmental corporate
or otherwise
and yet our angst
and our retribution is is pointed
towards the very folks who are being
victimized regularly it is as if we are
asking uh black folks who are
experiencing these levels of trauma to
rise above the trauma and eschew the
violence that has been
thrust upon us without any resources to
be healed to be restored or to be
stabilized and so i do believe that we
have a crisis moment around narrative
i do think that uh we we all want to be
safe
in our communities but the tough on
crime approach has proven to us to not
be the answer there's a scripture that
says um you know uh uh
if you hear the word but don't do the
word you are like a person who looks at
their reflection in the mirror and walks
away and forget what you saw
well i want to say that we can't last
year i'll talk about we need to uh you
know limit the footprint of policing
radically reimagine public safety and
then allow the conservative forces
largely led by police unions who are in
their own self-description
supportive of the authoritarian impulses
of donald trump and those forces we want
to unleash these individuals
into our communities to create safety
while they are all the while resisting
any form of reform and accountability
these are the folks we want to give more
money to i heard president biden at the
police foundation say we don't want to
defund the police we want to give you
more money
why so you can do
therapy
healing
we want to ask police officers to
provide therapy to pukey and raven
that's that's the most brilliant
community safety strategy
that the leader of this country
is proud to publicly proclaim and then
you want folks who actively work on this
every day to rob peter to pay paul to
sell chicken dinners to sell t-shirts to
fund a public safety strategy
that has been 400 years in the making of
a crisis
i do believe people that we must be as
serious about this problem
as we are about killing black people in
this country
this is a huge challenge for our
communities in the midst of a global
pandemic
that has ravaged the infrastructure the
familial ties and stability of black
communities and poor communities and
many communities and so i do believe the
conversation that we have today is a
conversation about politics and
conversation about you know the kind of
frameworks we use
to describe
and to define the phenomena that is
happening in our communities but it is
also about how do we love
black folk
right
uh how do we love folk into life
um and and and i i do know i'll say a
little bit more of this
later on but i do know that there are
folks within the black community who
live in very violent communities and it
is they themselves often calling for
more police
but i think it's important for us to
know that we have found strategies
that when people learn about these
strategies they actually will ask for
these strategies as well so the question
for us is how do we mainstream and
socialize
our broader public and conversation
around things that not only we know work
but that we know community members who
live in these communities will actually
embrace and remove the kind of political
uh uh anxiety of elected officials who
claim to want to end mass incarceration
they claim they want to end
criminalization they claim they want to
end police shootings
but don't want to do anything
systemically
to assist in that process i mean so i i
am very grateful to be included in this
conversation um
i i can go on and on but i'll stop there
because i i i would love to to continue
to
you know have the holy ghost be
activated in me by these great scholars
from these prestigious
uh and wonderful institutions
did you really end with holy spirit
activate is that what happened pastor
mike
hey man
if it ain't got that spirit ain't got
that swag
oh i could not appreciate the four of
y'all more um
what a tremendous set of of opening
remarks but i'm trying to distill themes
and before i get there everyone who is
here part of the audience we do want you
to be able to participate if you've got
questions please do put them in the chat
i will relay them here as part of our
ongoing conversation
but as i'm pulling out themes from um
where nikki started and passing like
where you end um
one of the themes that seems like it's
it's very clear is that the stories that
we're telling
are lies
right the the narratives that we've got
are insufficient for this moment um and
they're two examples that kind of uh uh
came out to me uh particularly brandon
as you were as you were talking
one was the tragic story of micaiah
bryant
right who if you recall um immediately
after the the trial derek shulman she's
a young african-american girl
who was shot and killed she was in
foster care she had a knife it looked in
the body cam video like she was lunging
out another girl
and initially because it was a
black girl it was a child who was killed
by law enforcement there was great alarm
and the body cam footage came out people
said well she had a knife it looked like
she was lunging what else could the
officer have done
it was a good shooting it was a fine
shooting how can you possibly object
and i thought about that between brandon
and pastor mike because the conversation
we had at my center
um a woman named tracy lloyd um with
with tears in her eyes
said we wouldn't have that conversation
as the only two options like she was
wronged where she deserved it
if if the people who were in charge of
keeping us safe
loved her
we would be able to imagine a world
where a child who was moved between
multiple foster homes which we know are
right for various kinds of abuse and
neglect
right
if that child's life was not about what
they chose to do in that moment
but the options that were afforded
to her
and
perhaps interestingly it paired in my
mind
with the conversation i was having last
night
about the tragic tragic killing of a
young woman
christina lee in chinatown in new york
and it looks as if the individual who
stabbed her with terrible murder
stabbed her 40 times in her own
apartment as a stranger by issue which
is incredibly rare as we as we know from
the literature just sort of the
caricature of the worst kinds of murder
but the individual who who stabbed her
was 25 years old
last address was a homeless shelter
and it was in a neighborhood where the
the community had gotten banned together
to say we don't want more homeless
shelters because we're scared of
homeless people
and it says if because the spectacle of
violence is so extraordinary
of of that physical violence it's so
extraordinary that it blinds us to
the violence of poverty and neglect that
causes it in the first place
and so with the concerns around
narrative these concerns about what is
missing the levels at which we're not
we're not having conversations
i have a question for for the panel and
i'm happy for you all to go in whatever
order and speak to each other which is
what obligation
is there
among black folks or folks who are
championing the black radical
imagination within this space
to the white assumptions
the white gaze upon this space
what things do black folks owe
to what white people imagine around
what's happening in black communities
because it does seem as if part of the
narratives that are are made invisible
are the narratives that are hardest to
explain to a white imagination of
blackness
so if that question makes sense i would
love for any of the panelists to go
ahead and get started and if nobody
wants to i absolutely will call on y'all
i i can start uh my first response is we
owe nothing
to the white imagination
um because the white imagination is not
constructed in a way that we're talking
about in the central goal of violence in
that way it's not it it's not
constructed to to serve black
communities and i think you know each
person laid that out particularly you
know pastor mike
um
you know this this idea
that
the solution lies in there i think has
been
um
you know challenged again and again and
again and i do see that as a problem of
the narrative and so thinking about this
i wrote an article recently um i am a
child right a girl child's truth and the
lies of law enforcement and it's about
the the girl child and i'm using here
the words of june jordan in rochester
new york who was pepper sprayed by
officers and in that piece i do a
step-by-step analysis of the encounter
and the moment in which the girl child
tells the truth
to law enforcement i am a child
calling them on their their failure to
recognize to see them but we understand
and your work as well professor golf
right that these institutions have been
conditioned
to mis read us right to to to to not see
us right uh and so you can imagine that
the the work will go into either
helping people see or keeping us alive
and the work of keeping us alive is deep
in in in the black radical uh tradition
right and in our in our daily practices
and if we think for example about
abolition and how that's mur you know
emerge as a possibility in a way in this
moment that it hasn't in a very long
time part of that is recognizing that
day-to-day practices not only abolition
as a political project but as a
political project that's it that that's
embedded in daily practices
that act of love that pastor mike is is
talking about i know a young person
is is is is is is leading down a path in
my neighborhood how do i approach them
understanding
the challenges with that which is
something i write about in the chosen
ones
building that world and one of the
things that i've learned from from folks
who are doing this work over the last
couple of years as we imagine like you
know the top down
at the top people have moved through
this racial reckoning really quickly the
people on the ground are still doing the
work why are they doing the work because
they're doing the care work that that's
what it means to be a community it's
what it means to care for each other and
people so people are doing that work and
people are going to continue to do that
work
i do think that thinking about investing
in that work is really important
the narrative for investment i think you
know pat's work is is compelling for
folks
because of that and at the same time
it has to be a narrative that is
centered in in the value of black life
and black humanity and those two right
can often collide
and can i can i just add and say it must
be centered in
black life and black humanity but also
black leadership
or
leadership of those who demonstrate love
public love for black people
and so i do find it quite problematic
that um you know
we
we are allowing
this narrative around crime
um and violence in our communities
to to
um
to
uh gestate or at least to go mainstream
through the voices of some black
institutional leaders both political
religious cultural and otherwise
um you know it's a fascinating thing you
know a lot of a lot of the narrative
around
um um you know the the the rising crime
and and the need for uh this kind of
punitive response
you know in the 90s we know had lots of
faith leaders standing up in press
conferences with mayors and elected
officials you know saying this is the
way forward
and yet we also know that over the last
couple years events like uh uh
uh
what was the name of this this thing
that the police were doing it was called
um uh
faith and the blue or something like
that these these targeted outreaches
to
black religious leaders
to sit down with law enforcement and
craft public safety plans when the
average faith leader is not even in
relationship
with you know some of the the very
impacted individuals and i say this as a
favor because i had lots of clergy
calling me across the country said
pastor why should i get involved in this
and i said
if your first conversation
around violence is with a prosecutor a
politician or a police officer then you
ought to probably stay in the stands
till you talk to pookie and ray ray
right because you don't have enough
information
right to be in that conversation a way
that actually will get the the result
that you say you want which is peace in
our communities and so right now as the
bite administration um rightly has been
pushing out this five billion dollar
uh investment that folks like in our fan
peace coalition other folks you know
gave them the information architecture
to construct we're seeing right now
across the country that mayors have
received of arp funds over almost a
billion dollars i think of their
commitments to put arp funds american
rescue plan dollars into community
advice interventions and less than 10
of those funds have even moved into the
community so it is not just even about
accessing resources about having the
leadership in place at the at the
executive level at the communal level
and in the neighborhoods that can show
that their love for our communities sees
them not just as a problem to be solved
but a solution to be unleashed and that
work i think is really the next frontier
of the black radical tradition not just
from a scholastic point of view but what
does it mean to radically love black
folks to be proximal to the conditions
of black folks what does it mean for
intellectual giants uh in cities and
universities to be in proximity to
organizers on the ground and folks in
neighborhoods who are impacted by this
so our work can be braided together i
think that is another part of the
conversation of how we collapse uh these
false distinctions and roles into
something that could be much more
glorious and healing
now you go ahead brad
yeah i am
i'm really taking the endeavor part of
this seriously so i'm i'm trying out
ideas and i'm curious to get a response
um because i think
you know there's an amazing essay
by frederick douglass that i love to
teach called is it right and wise to
kill a kidnapper and he's talking about
fugitive slave catchers and what i love
about that essay is that it captures a
real problem in black political thought
is that you're always thinking about
what are rights right what are duties
obligations what's legitimate
um what what do you have to do as a
matter of morality
and you're also trying to think about
things that would be good
right so you might not be obligated to
do them but they would be good if you in
fact did do them
and things that would be prudent so
things that might be wise to do and may
be neither good
nor just
uh and i go into that digression just to
say
i agree
that we probably have no obligation
to
dispel racist fantasies
uh that proliferate through the
population
or punitive
stigmas against the ghetto poor
but i think it is probably good to do so
and probably wise to do so
uh insofar as we think
that there is no plausible go it alone
nationalist strategy
and again it goes back to part of what i
was getting at in my remarks is that one
of my concerns with the community
violence paradigm
is i think it does a lot as an
explanatory paradigm because it's coming
out of sociology community studies
social ecology
but it brings a bunch of normative
resonances from communitarianism from
nationalism about the ethics of
community
and the question is who's in the
community and who's not
if we respond to pastor mike who says
do we belong to america
the right arguments might not entail
entrenching
the problem deeper in an isolated
neighborhood space
they might be about tethering these
things to a broader
metropolitan strategy a broader
national strategy
that's one of my concerns here and i'm
just curious as to how people respond to
it because i think
um one of the things that's really
remarkable to me about the last 10 15
years is that all the hard culture work
artistic work
uh hip-hop film music uh
hard political work and activism i think
has done a lot to really change how
people think about the agential
nature of crime
in ghetto communities and the
attribution of moral responsibility for
it and it and i think it's created a
broader constituency than we've ever
seen for these movements even though
it's not enough to win as of yet
so so i'm i'm suspicious of the reflex
of worry about it
you know i i appreciate that and i i
would say that that it it is good to do
the work but it does not emerge out of
an obligation right as an obligation
suggests criteria you know
characteristics of a relationship that
aren't actually the relationship
that we have right and and and the
challenge that we're confronting and and
the language and the narrative i think
is really important we are talking about
the evolution of a system of racial
domination in which law enforcement has
played a central role both formal and
informal right interleague extra legal
you know for you know forms of law
enforcement and that's what we are are
contending with right and a body politic
that has supported that in its different
iterations over time uh and so we do the
work because the same reasons that the
boys did the work and id wells did the
work right and on and on we do the work
and we have the conversations within
right that that aren't directed toward
the white gays and move us forward
but i wouldn't say i would stop short of
saying it it's an obligation it really
is
about saving our own lives
and
and i don't say that in a hyperbolic
sense at all i mean i know you
appreciate that but when you look at the
historical record that's what folks are
trying to do and somehow we imagine that
that we are in a different moment and
yet that is still what we're trying to
do
all right
yeah
can i react to go ahead yeah go ahead
just real quick i want to react to
another part of what brandon said
because
you know i i do find the language of
community violence
um as a
kind of discrete descriptor of the way
in which violence uniquely visits black
and brown communities within the kind of
larger context of the gun violence
conversation in this country to to be an
outgrowth of how many of us who have
been working at the intersection of gun
violence victimization black and brown
communities largely found our
experiences being erased if not
altogether
left to a law enforcement punitive only
conversation so as to when you join a
gun
violence prevention conversation and the
only conversation about second amendment
rights right and then folks are like
well what about these other public
health related strategy what about
talking about criminal justice within
the gun
violence prevention movement or talking
about uh you know issues of poverty and
other forms of violence we were told
well that is not gun violence prevention
work right and so we had to create new
language and i just say all that to say
part of what i think could be a an
endeavor
is how do we
how do we create new language together
um that actually captures that which we
say we are trying
to accomplish and i do think this is
perhaps part of the project of building
and reimagining public safety by
censoring those directly impacted by
these issues uh versus us doing a
reactionary um you know move whether
it's around narrative policy and or
solutions to these arbitrary rises and
spikes
in crime and violence that are often
politicized
in the moment but not necessarily over a
long period of time
done as a constructive project around
democracy
because you know how can one
um
you know really love
the country or the city they're in if
they can't even imagine they're going to
live very long
within it right it is it is almost you
know a decoupling of one spirit in
humanity and so i do think the community
violence narrative is is
is both helpful but also challenging and
i i hope we can endeavor to again be
very clear about what we want to say and
how we want to imagine the world for
when we're talking about these issues
i appreciate all that and brandon i want
to add too and then pivot to a different
question uh which is a synthesis of a
couple of that i've gotten in the chat
here
because i think part of what you're
bringing up is that regardless of what a
moral obligation might be particularly
from
a collective and community
perspective
there is work that is likely necessary
in order to achieve certain aims
this uh group is not called um black
elected political uh work in the context
of community violence um it is called uh
uh right black activism and so i'm
wondering the degree to which and pata
if i can uh sort of direct this uh to
you um the degree to which it is clear
what the role of activism should be
versus what the role of the state should
be in this particularly at a moment when
we're seeing the federal government is
putting more money into programs like
violence interruption right and that
federal and state dollars are going more
to these nonprofit community elements
the non-profit sphere has traditionally
been supposed to be for places that the
state need not or cannot go and yet as
we think about scaling responses to
community violence we see the state
starting to get involved which leads to
this sort of muddying
where there are folks who are saying no
defund the police as the slogan needs to
serve these particular partisan uh
interests versus it has nothing to do
with y'all please don't talk about it
because you didn't show up at the
rallies so it has so so you don't get a
say
so pat can you talk just a little bit
about um this moment that we've got
where there is funding
flowing to nonprofits from the state
and whether or not some of the work that
nonprofits have been doing particularly
the work you've been studying belongs
with the state or does it belong with
the community
yeah big questions um you know i think
of this this
topic that we're talking about was
created by the state uh this was this
was a result of
interventions uh over
uh a long period of time and i think one
of the
points that i heard dr terry push us to
to maybe think about is
how do we
how do we talk about this this problem
of violence and expand it so that it
we're talking about it in relational
terms we're talking about it uh not as a
as a problem that is uh concentrated in
low-income communities of color but as a
consequence
of a set of interventions that have been
carried out over decades and longer
where and i saw elizabeth hinton is in
the
the room somewhere she should
everything that i've learned about this
i've learned from reading her work and
other historians but this is
a product
this is actively produced when the
federal government
invested in an interstate highway system
and subsidized mortgages that allowed
people who could afford a car and firms
uh were able to leave central city
unions uh central cities to avoid big
city unions that had become more and
more powerful
when
we give enormous capacity to uh local
municipal governments to decide who can
live in that space uh so if you like for
instance if you want to look at st louis
and ferguson well first think back to
when uh the white population of st louis
was subsidized to leave to the suburbs
and then
formed new municipalities and then zoned
it all for single-family
homes so that their property values rose
really quickly and the property values
in st louis fell very quickly that's the
basis for how you get decades later what
happened to michael brown that's the
basis for how st louis became the most
violent city in the country those active
interventions which now take the form of
land use regulations and gated
communities uh and and this spatial
infrastructure of inequality that the
state has built over time
so when i'm listening to dr terry i'm it
in my mind it it it reinforced in this
notion that we have to understand this
challenge in relational terms we have to
understand it as a consequence of
conscious intentional interventions
carried out
over decades that have led to this form
of extreme inequality which then creates
the conditions for violence to emerge
when people retreat from their homes
when they've the core institutions of
the community are not supported then you
create the conditions where violence can
emerge so
circling back to your your
question phil
i think it is
unfair i think it is unsustainable and i
think it is ineffective
to think of this project of of
responding uh to these interventions
carried over out over decades
with a and another project that doesn't
feature the state with another project
that doesn't assume that we need public
funding 120 billion dollars a year spent
on law enforcement
you know what if what if the groups run
by pastor mike and fun peace had a
hundred billion dollar budget per year
per year not five billion dollars at one
point in time but 100 billion dollars
per year
what would what would communities look
like at that point uh and so you know i
always go back when i lived in manhattan
for uh uh 11 years
and i was in nyu housing uh right in
washington square and
i was not once asked
to
volunteer my time or my money to go deal
with the problem of violence in my
community
and so if we're going to mount a
sustained project to deal with this i
don't think it can rely on people
volunteering i don't think it can rely
on organizations that are fighting for
every dollar they receive i think it has
to be a project that is funded through
the mechanism of the state
and i'll just add to that that
as much as i i appreciate pastor mike
and the work that he does and the work
that folks i've written about are doing
as well there's a way that that can
presume that the conditions don't change
so that the organizations are going to
be needed to do it to do the work that
they're doing now so if we take a step
back we're actually talking about a
project of reparations right an
investment right a a an acknowledgement
of the harm and some financial redress
for all of all of what uh the state
interventions that that pat just laid
out
but we stopped short of that right uh
and because and there's a reason that we
stopped short of that and our stopping
short of that is what allows the problem
to continue and us to have these
conversations about you know which kinds
of interventions
make the most sense right and what we
ought to do
not acknowledging that we are not all
the same we right and the community is
not all the same community right the
politics of the community are real and
those are also manufactured uh both
internally but also by the state so i
think part of of of what i've i've tried
to do over the last couple of years is
to think
in a real you know honest way about the
situation in which we find ourselves
right and if we think about you know the
the what what pat laid out around
residence presidential segregation in
the construction of whiteness
and the battle
for whiteness
right now and what we saw in the
insurrection is kind of crisis of
whiteness like
what is whiteness going to mean in this
country and that's consequential for
black people to extend we're talking
about black people right because it
always includes some reference to black
people and the condition of black people
whether or not they're not whether or
not they're whether they are there or
not right in in this nation so the
question isn't as much
about you know are we part of america
right it is is america an america that
has the kinds of institutions that can
include us
so what i've done there is to take us
like many degrees away from what people
the narrative of gun violence right and
building on what other folks have said
and you know i say that not to to stop
uh put a halt to the conversation but
just to kind of
to i really you know to really get us uh
you know closer to the problem as we're
dealing with it
you know as it as as you know as we're
confronting it
yeah bran did i see you take yourself
off mu you wanna get in on this
yeah um
because i think to this this this point
you know we you know we're we're
thinking in the aftermath of some really
momentous things and i really
appreciated how you set us up phil um
it's not just the biggest protest
movement in world history
uh it's also the largest influx of cash
into black political black-led political
organizations in
history and i think one of the things
that
many of us knew before last month but
have all been forced to deal with in
public last month
is that that didn't go well
um
cash came in there wasn't infrastructure
to deal with it
uh it papered over a lot of rhetoric
papered over
who was making decisions
who what constituencies they were
accountable to
uh
what philanthropic dollars demanded in
return for their commitments
uh
that's a whole set of democratic
deficits that emerge
when this happens in an ad hoc fashion
uh as a dance between philanthropists
activists and a media climate that
uh gravitates towards spectacular acts
of violence
so i just raised that to say that one of
the biggest problems for black activism
one which we have
basically no conceptual resources to
deal with because it hasn't been a
problem before
it's like how to manage enormous amounts
of money
in a way that is democratically
defensible
or if not it's not going to appeal to
norms of democracy give us reasons why
we should not demand those democratic
norms uh be shown fidelity to
uh
the the
alternative what i think professor
sharkey's laying out
is really a remaking of the state
and again that's that's just not a
project that black political thought has
tended
to have a lot of resources to to try to
think but it's our opportunity to do so
to
establish a new progressivism that
really thinks about what might new and
novel state institutions look like
as we try to onboard
the work of community repair
into a state apparatus that might be
deserving
of the ascent and respect and commitment
of who are the people who are right now
the truly disadvantaged
yeah ryan i just want to pick up on one
thread of that i'm so glad that you were
talking about the amount of money uh
that philanthropy puts in to black lego
organizations blacklight political power
but it has been to the the criminal
legal space and the public safety space
in particular um over the last two years
um i want to just uh sort of add
friendly amendments on two parts one
while the the public rhetoric was about
black led organizations and the public
scrutiny has absolutely been black led
organizations the majority of the money
that went into the public safety space
was not to black-led organizations right
um and
this sort of new problem of a sort of
windfall of capital within the space is
absolutely new to black political
projects but not new to non-profit
spaces
non-profits right so there there are
examples of this happening within uh the
climate justice space um within uh
women's reproductive health space um
with the sexual orientation spaces where
exactly the same kinds of sort of
cardboard edifices on the fronts of
nonprofits fall down uh with the
windfall of cash right and then the
ecosystem sort of reconstructs itself
amidst that this is a predictable cycle
when we rely on non-governmental so it's
philanthropic non-governmental resources
to get stuff done and yet i do believe
that the narrative that's going to
emerge from this is going to be quite
distinct because of the racialization of
this work right
oh boy do i wish that we had seven hours
to do just this i want to be responsive
to all the messages that are coming in
it looks like 100 of them are direct
messages um right now so i want to make
a pivot because i've had two folks ask
now about
um given that we're talking about uh
a tension between whether or not we want
community to genuinely lead
outside of government where we want to
be remaking the state as brandon ufran
um but there's a question as to what is
the role
of activism in response if it is
genuinely community
or to be community-led and responding to
community trauma per se
as opposed to medical community and the
state considering the historic neglect
of community trauma particularly in
black communities and pastor mike i'm
going to go ahead and give that to you
first
well i i think the role is of both and
but the emphasis to me you know
continues to have to be around you know
both leadership and agencies um you know
i think many of us who are in that quote
activism organizing space
appreciate that
every system we engage is one built
inherently with anti-blackness embedded
in it like none of us are like walking
around here really thinking that um
whether it's a black brown
latina latin
you
latinx
lgbtq person leading such institution nc
blackness is all through that
um and yet we know that you know we we
must figure out ways to redeem what's
redeemable and transform what must be
jettisoned
and so for us it's about imagination
right it's about how can we
um create new structures within the
redeemable parts of these systems um
that have community power and leadership
and accountability at the center of it
um not in some kind of ceremonial way
but in a real distinct way we can fire
we can hire we can audit we can make
corrective um you know kind of decision
making along the way
uh to ensure that you know community
uh activism interest uh priorities
remain at the heart of these said both
interventions and or kind of
programmatic responses to
both the immediacy of the problem and
certainly the kind of long-term
trajectory of the solution
one thing we ask often and we wrestle
with this in our organizing means i love
to put this out for folks here is you
know what is the trajectory
um the timeline the kind of hansel and
breto crumbs hansel and gretel crumbs
that you put
so people can follow along in the
journey
towards a abolitionist
uh you know
um reality or a a
a reality where police budgets are
less than you know the majority or
significant part of a general fund and
we are
as as uh brother sharkey's mentioned
literally that
dollar for dollar investing in both
community healing community repair
reproductions like you know what's the
timeline to that how do we get there how
do we help people appreciate that
organizing along the way activism along
the way is the trajectory of that and
it's very hard when the material
conditions of people every day
uh are experiencing the
the concreteness of the loss of lies the
the the bruising of bodies the the the
intimate partner violence the the the
the lethal conflicts that play out
literally outside people's homes like
folks can't think 20 years in the future
if they can't imagine how to get their
kid to school today right and so our
task is to help balance the tension
between the here and now and the black
future right i hear full time about
black history you know when you talk
about black future i say no we talk
about all of it but but not one sector
of our work can hold all of it right um
and so this is where i think um it has
to be a broken in in my mind both around
imagining
around um
implementing around evaluating around
sustaining um and some of that will be
done in some of these systems that have
both redemptive and unredemptive
components of it and something will have
to be done apart from those systems the
question is can our brilliance our
humility our collaboration um our
intentionality help us be able to
to change both the near term and the
far-term conditions um i think that is a
big part of work but i am always you
know captured by this question um dr
king how long right and i think that is
a question for so many in the community
how long must we live in these
conditions
um
without reprise and and and you know um
reparations i i we a lot of us talk
about reparations but
you know we don't even have all
every black person in this country
feeling like who should get reparation
what does reparations look like you know
if you're from jamaica some people don't
think you should get reparations like my
god
when did that start happening right so
we we got a lot of work to do to just
bring us together but i i do find this
to be at both end at least in how i'm
hearing the question
yeah i think that's true of this
conversation too black folks don't all
agree right people don't all agree on on
the starting point right and so what i
see that question as a starting point in
the same way that pat's talking about
the body of research i think the body of
research on reparations is building up
as well i think uh sandy dary william
darity
uh work on um on reparations and the
distinct kind of the justifications for
it and how it might play out is is one
example of that um i just want to go
back to one point um and and brandon you
might you know
because of your expertise you can you
can help me think about this
but the idea i don't think you're saying
that that black people haven't been
engaged with the making of the state or
maybe distinguishing between black
people and blackness right because we
know the state as it exists is in
response in part to blackness and
understanding of of that right and so
the question for me is
how is it that the demands that are
being made are incorporated into uh not
just the state but that a state that is
when we think about abolitionists
imaginings can actually create the kinds
of institutions that are necessary for
the for the the population of people we
have within these borders now while also
accounting right for
the sovereign territory and the unseated
terrorists and and all that so that's
that's a you know that's that's a big
question but thinking
you know
acknowledging the fact that even in this
conversation there is a possibility to
remake the state but it can't be on the
conditions of the state and that's why i
keep coming back to this point that that
we have to confront confront directly
the violence of the state you can't kind
of you know move around it and and what
does that mean in a very material sense
it take you pastor mike's point that
means that when a young man tells me
that he grew up with the hands of police
officers down his pants
as a consequence of this war on drugs
that was a war on young people
my politics my practice has to get in
the way of that has to interrupt that
has to disrupt that because whatever you
think about crime rates uh and bringing
them down that cannot be a way in which
we do it right and so and and we know
like it's just a history of
black feminist thoughts shows us the
many many ways
that black women have cared for one
another
cared for the community right uh and so
that we know those very material
practices in in a tradition of that
exists and so you know i think it is
this both and
but we cannot get out of this
where we are we cannot do this remaking
this this reimagining this
transformation
without a direct confrontation
confrontation which will feel
antagonistic to some folks
with state violence
yeah i don't i don't disagree with that
i mean i should i should be more precise
where i
i think you know look we have an
enormously rich tradition i've devoted
my life to studying black political
thought
i think like any genre of political
thought
they're things that
traditions fixate on because they have
to
um so so
you see in other traditions like if you
take
kind of 19th and 20th century german
political thought you just see a lot of
focus on how to develop a bureaucracy
because they're engaged in the process
of doing that
uh not a lot of our thinkers were
allowed to participate
in the active construction of the
bureaucracies that we live under we
have a much richer tradition of how to
think about the ethics of protests and
the ethics of resistance so that's all i
was just trying to say is that for for
our generation of thinkers
one of the difficult moves is going to
be
you know coming down on
this question of
do we need to develop more sustained
forms of statecraft and how can we
rethink the state what is our conception
of the state
um
and and what might state institutions
look like i was using the progressive
era as an analogy because it's one of
the moments in american history where
left liberals spend a lot of time
thinking about how the state might
operate very differently than it did
prior right getting rid of patronage
appointments um trying to think about
the spoil system things like that
so
just one quick example
you know
do we have a unitary conception of the
state that we're operating with right or
is the state a jumble of competing
interest in institutions
which we might see some element of and
use them as a counterpower to parts of
the state that we're antagonistic toward
that's just an open political theory
question that i don't think we have a
lot of debate about right now in the
space of public safety
um
so i wanted to say that and then the
second thing just more directly to
pastor mike's point which i think is
really important
so how do we convince people how do we
where the bread crumbs you know use the
analogy of breadcrumbs
it's like
a lot of my work right now is about
narratives narratives of history and one
of my deep concerns is
the popularity of what i call ironic
narratives but other people might call
pessimist narratives or afro-pessimist
narratives
that
really diminish the significance of
partial victories
and treat them as illusory meaningless
non-events
i think that's really demoralizing to a
social movement struggle to
to the kind of practice that du bois
called the long siege
uh which i think is would any struggle
against the history of white supremacy
in this country and the current practice
of white supremacy and this country is
going to look like
and i think we have to be really careful
that although such narratives can feel
cathartic because they allow us to
denounce all existence in one sweep
that they can be really demoralizing on
the ground
so that's one thing i think we have to
avoid are narratives that diminish
partial victories we need to find ways
of lifting up partial victories while
still acknowledging how partial they are
and then the other thing i was gonna say
is that from from african american
history i i always enamored with
you know i'm teaching class on malcolm x
now
i always teach classes on the black
power movement and think a lot about the
panthers
and i think for everyone
um
who struggles with the history of black
radicalism one of the things that's
really appealing about those two
movements the movement around malcolm x
and the movement around the panthers is
that they were able to get people who
are involved in the perpetration of
public space violence
to participate in a actively in
political struggle
and to me that just is still the holy
grail that's still proof of concept can
you
can you show
people in black communities poor black
communities that you can reach
folks who
everyone else thinks nobody can reach
and that need to be thrown away need to
be locked away incapacitated
when you can reach those people and show
their political moral agency
their genius
their creativity
i think there's just something still
spectacular and compelling and
persuasive about that project but it is
extraordinarily difficult
i really am i'm at this point i went
from frustrated to being angry that this
conversation can't go longer um i want
to respect folks time we're looking
we're coming up on about 14 minutes left
and i swore to all the panelists that we
have a chance to do closing remarks um
so we're going to go through those
closing remarks um i part of me wants to
know about what is and isn't new brandon
you talked about partial victories and i
thought i was in pastor mike's church
when i was saying amen to it um the
tensions between what we can get today
versus what we must demand for tomorrow
which are clearly part of this long
struggle but feel like they're having a
different conversation right now all of
that but i'll i'll leave with this
prompt and then ask folks to take just
two to three minutes to wrap up respond
to the prompt or don't but the the
prompt coming in again as a synthesis
from a couple of direct messages
we've talked this there's a conversation
framed around what organizers and
activists can do in this moment
um and if you could name
the one thing
the one thing the one constraint on
activism right now
the one constraint that if we removed it
would be the biggest lever on change
that we could do the one constraint that
could be removed go ahead and name that
and then go ahead and wrap up we're
gonna go in the same order uh dr nikki
jones if you want to go ahead and start
us off
there is no one thing right uh we are
operating in a structural context that
positions
activists and organizers and there is
overlap and there's distinctions
in certain ways
has them in a place
um and that that is is is built in to
the work right that that has been
the long struggle
i'm not a pessimist and and yet i don't
see that changing
in the near future
what i know is happening
is that the people
who were instigating and motivating the
work that led to the uprisings of summer
2020 have not let up
and they are continuing to do that work
and what becomes transformative in any
moment of rupture is the set of ideas
that that percolate to the to the
surface
and that's why this rupture summer 2020
between reform and abolition
was so significant and remains so
consequential so even defund as a slogan
didn't emerge in that moment i'm sure as
folks here appreciate it emerged in
oakland years before
right in in response to a very material
material problem and then and then that
leads to the certain and the reaction to
that is what leads to change we don't
want to defund the police but maybe
we'll re you know think about re
reallocating resources uh maybe we'll
think about a department of public
safety in minneapolis which got 43 of
the vote which is not nothing and
probably before this moment wouldn't
have gotten 12 percent of the vote right
and so i just want to bring our
attention to the the fact that that this
this work is happening this change is is
happening
and the people who are closest to the
problem are the ones who are figuring it
out the question for the the we that
exists
here in some respect and i'll think i'll
say something specifically about the we
in the academy
is to acknowledge our role
in producing the conditions that we have
talked about over the course of our time
together today and to rethink how we
reallocate our resources right so that
we are are funneling the the power of
the university to those who need it most
so to me i see that as the kind of um
you know the practice
um the liberatory practice the fugitive
practice that we need to be invested in
in this moment and is that and that is
actually most um sensitive right and has
the kind of most accurate reading of the
conditions in which we find
ourselves i'll stop there
thanks thank you
yeah
dr pat sharkey
uh so i've i've learned when i should
sit out a question and listen uh and and
i think this this is a question that
where it's better
for me to listen than anything else but
what i will say is that as
following up on nikki's powerful point
uh about what role academics play
one of the things that i've learned
about particularly
my role what a white academic can play
who doesn't do the work on the ground uh
who doesn't do the ethnography that
nikki does who
does quantitative work to try to
understand
uh these these
challenges we're talking about um
i've found that my job is to
relentlessly focus on explanation
relentlessly move past
the
observation of inequality the
description of inequality and toward
explanation and that's why you know i go
to
elizabeth hinton's work and and why it's
so powerful because it gives academics
the tools to say okay here's a challenge
now
let's understand where this arose and
what were the intentional policies and
what were the impacts of those policies
and those social movements that led
to this form of inequality that we're
now seeing uh and and so i'll stop there
and just say the
i see my job as an academic to just
relentlessly focus on explanation and
never stop
until i have made the empirical point
about what led to this point
thank you pat dr brandon terry final
thoughts
yeah well this is a really hard question
um
and i think
for me the the biggest obstacle
and i think the biggest thing that's
changed
since the last wave uh the last major
wave of black radicalism in the late
1960s and early 1970s
is the carceral state itself i mean
we've just taken a lot of
brilliant
hardworking
um
interesting
people out of circulation in public
space
and unlike
the era of the great prison movements of
the late 1960s and early 1970s it's also
really really difficult um to organize
in prisons
uh in in ways i mean it was always
difficult to organize a prisons but it's
it's become in some respects even more
difficult people can't even get their
hands on books to read
without without uh severe censorship and
surveillance uh repression and these
things have only gotten more intense uh
in the in the wake of the pandemic where
there's been
really harsh lockdowns and lots of
facilities
um and so one of the one of the problems
that creates is that it really
intensifies the disconnect
that that pastor mike was speaking about
of people trying to connect the lived
experience of people
most susceptible to and most likely to
perpetrate
what we're calling community violence
and the politics that emerge from it and
we haven't really been able to develop
there's some great experiments in this
but there
there hasn't been a strategy that that
quite seems scalable as of yet
about how to overcome
that the repressive function of of the
carceral state
on radical politics in this moment
so so that would be the biggest thing
and i think as as academics
you know one of the things we can
contribute
to that project
is really doing the hard work of
normative analysis
to try to you know the old worker
critical theory clarifying
the struggles of the age like let's
really clarify what people are arguing
why they're saying things are unjust
what kinds of norms they're appealing to
what are the differences between duties
uh goods uh and just prudential
considerations why those might matter
because they help open up the space of
persuasion
for allies we're asking to risk
a lot in in in the struggles against um
uh
authoritarianism whether it takes the
form of the prison or whether whether it
takes the form of the anti-democratic
movements we're seeing insurgent today
thank you brandon and last but certainly
not least pastor mike
um i
you know this this question about what
is one thing i'm like dr jones uh
you know
uh
and i say god i need father son holy
spirit we gotta start at least with
three things a good good preacher you
know in me but but i i do worry about
isolationism you know like
um
that that
we can we can become isolated in our
silos
um by just the rigor of the work that we
are all called to do uniquely and and
that isolationism creates
um you know a level of of
incompatibility over time where we just
can't even
we can say the same word but not mean
the same thing and so you know i wonder
like can we can we walk together um
how can we walk together
you know i'm finding this to be the
biggest challenge in our movement space
post the ferguson uprising etc black
lives matter however you want to
describe it um
we
a lot of us aren't walking together
anymore and and that's just within one
part of the movement like how can we
walk together as
you know across disciplines across the
academy across religious you know
movements across uh you know elected
officials like how can we walk
together and it is frightening to
for me to think about these
authoritarian impulses sweeping the
country and we who are in its crosshairs
can't figure out how to walk together
not in some kumbaya way but just in a
relational
manner where we can
have a conversation over time and do the
dreaming that we all
say we want to do right it's not to me
about intentions it's just about how can
we
just functionally walk together this
capitalistic economy that
you know makes us all have to write
papers priests methods like you know i
got to get a new thing to say every week
right the same message every week
differently right a capitalistic
endeavor somebody's right there right or
gotta figure out a new organizing plan
every week every month
and that work in and of itself it i
think often keeps our relationships from
being um
go deep deep in and and
and um
life-giving so that that's what i would
say um and i i do believe we have
massive opportunities
but it is still early um these same
opportunities could become trojan horses
to continue to you know fund the state
the incarceral state the the police
state
all these things that we know are
problematic and so i do hope
um that as we continue to lean into this
moment
we can maximize these opportunities to
to both
recreate but also
dismantle those things that that cause
us harm
thanks for thanks for having me though
dr phil and everybody
see i thought we were so close we were
so close to getting out of one session
together with no dr phil references and
yet there at the very end
my brother
um
this has been such a nourishing
conversation
thank the four of y'all before i let
folks go i want to make sure that we get
a special shout out to vanessa epps
who helped get all the logistics of this
together make sure that our panelists
were here um you know she made all of us
look significantly better than we would
have otherwise so thank you so much
vanessa thank you all to coming for
coming i cannot wait for the next and
the next of these endeavors but please
join me raise your hands take yourselves
off mute um and thanking our panelists
for sharing their wisdom and their
brilliance with us today thank you all
so so so much
thank you thank you thank you so much
thank you thank you